bonsoir bonsoir à tous il se trouve que
je suis déjà intervenu dans cet amphi il
ya quelques temps je me sente
en confiance pour aborder avec vous un
sujet délicat il faut être clair ce dont
je vais parler maintenant et n'est pas
facile nous nous sommes trompés nous
nous sommes trompés dans les deux sens
du terme
nous sommes trompés bien sûr parce que
nous avons fait des erreurs mais nous
nous sommes trompés aussi peut-être
parce que nous nous sommes raconter des
histoires éventuellement même nous nous
sommes un peu menti aujourd'hui la
situation je ne vais pas refaire un état
des lieux ce soir sur la crise
écologique
la catastrophe écologique je suis de
ceux qui considèrent qu'il ne s'agit ni
d'une crise d'une catastrophe mais
littéralement d'une destruction des
conditions de vie une destruction de l'
équilibre écologique vital même si le
terme est un peu délicat à utiliser
aujourd'hui littéralement il fait
jusqu'à moins 50 degrés en amérique du
nord et plus 50 degrés en australie la
planète a peut être extrêmement rarement
rencontré de tels contrastes et les
écosystèmes en souffrent directement la
littérature fin je vous laisserai
constate consulter la presse parce que
maintenant la question de du risque
d'effondrement et dans toute la presse
aujourd'hui des espèces des chevaux par
exemple disparaissent sous la canicule
en australie en ce moment même ce que je
voudrais ce soir c'est nous fait
réfléchir à notre position d'être humain
dans cette perspective écologique pour
le moins inquiétante et reprenons
quelques grands paramètres de notre
organisation de notre façon d'être au
monde et de notre façon d'avoir des
relations avec notre milieu notre
environnement
reprenons quelques uns de ces paramètres
les limites sous c'est facile nous
prenons des ressources dans
l'environnement et nous pouvons vérifier
chez nous qu'au bout d'un moment ça
s'arrête de prendre des ressources dans
un environnement dans notre cuisine
quand le placard et vise le placard est
vide et il faut absolument aller au
supermarché en bas pour le remplir à
nouveau pour nous c'est facile parce que
on a des supermarchés mais nous n'avons
pas de planète b voilà c'est très simple
et on peut le vérifier chez nous un
autre de ces paramètres que nous pouvons
vérifier chez nous c'est notre
dépendance strictes à l'énergie nos
sociétés très complexe qui nous rendent
beaucoup de services qui nous permette
une santé plutôt très bonne services de
soins très bon concert
beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie et nous en
sommes dépendants on pourrait imaginer
qu'on pourrait se passer d'énergie quoi
et maintenir le même niveau de vie les
mêmes avantages
et bien la plante qui est dans votre
salon elle dépend aussi de l'énergie
vous voyez que si vous fermez les volets
et que vous arrêter d'alimenter cette
plante en énergie solaire
elle va fait elle va dépérir
nécessairement elle va finir par mourir
nous sommes aussi totalement dépendant
de l'énergie que cette plante c'est
encore une chose que vous pouvez
vérifier chez vous je vous proposerai de
le faire c'est assez simple les deux
expériences suivantes sont un peu plus
un peu plus complexe ou en tout cas vous
verrez qu'elles sont très difficiles à
réaliser mais vous pouvez vraiment faire
le test your vous fait un gâteau vous
l'oubliez dans le four il est trop cuit
il est brûlé essayer de récupérer les
ingrédients de votre gâteau pour en
faire un autre à la cuisson idéale
vous n'y arriverez pas ça s'appelle le
principe de non réversibilité je
simplifie à peine lorsqu'il transporte
lorsqu une transformation physique est
fait il n'est pas possible de revenir en
arrière à notre échelle nous ne pouvons
pas réparé pour revenir à l'écologie les
écosystèmes que nous avons détruit c'est
impossible c'est hors de notre portée
les espèces qui ont disparu ou ont
disparu et vous pouvez vérifier chez
vous le principe de non réversibilité
une autre expérience vous partez en
vacances vous allez à la mer et vous
vous garez juste derrière la plage
derrière les dunes et l'expérience que
je vous propose c'est de prendre le soft
vous aviez à porter pour permettre aux
enfants de faire des châteaux de sable
et vous allez chercher le sable de la
dune vous remplissez votre saut et
l'expérience consistant jeter tout le
sable sur le parking où vous êtes garé
et vous allez essayer de récupérer le
sable pour remplir le seau et vous allez
constater immédiatement que ça vous
prendra un temps beaucoup plus long que
de prendre le sable et de le jeter
que ça vous va ça va vous prendre une
énergie infiniment plus grande qu'il
vous aura fallu pour remplir le seau et
le gentil et qu'en plus vous ne pourrez
jamais récupéré tous les grains de sable
cette expérience toute simple que vous
pouvez tous faire c'est l'entropie là
encore que je simplifie appel et
l'entreprise nous contraint dans notre
relation à l'environnement
parce qu'elle nous empêche par exemple
d'aller chercher les perturbateurs
endocriniens qui sont maintenant on le
sait un petit peu partout dans notre
propre chaîne alimentaire
l'entropie elle nous empêche de
récupérer les plastiques qui se
dispersent dans l'océan et qui se
désagrège qui finissent en
microparticules les récupérer ça
impliquerait de passer une énergie
beaucoup plus grande qu il nous aurait
fallu pour qu'il nous a fallu pour les
fabriquer c'est une impossibilité
physique
dernier point plus critique encore
puisque j'ai parlé de réchauffement
climatique au début le co2 que nous
émettons dans l'atmosphère lorsqu'il y
est
l'entropie nous interdit de le récupérer
à moins de dépenser plus d'énergie qui
nous aura fallu pour émettre ses
molécules de co2 alors ces principes là
ce sont de grandes contraintes physiques
qui sont parfaitement vérifiables ils
sont vérifiées les scientifiques les
connaissent bien ce que je vous propose
aujourd'hui c'est de les réintégrer dans
notre réflexion pour comprendre nous
allons vous êtes la jeune génération
vous êtes celle qui constate les dégâts
qu'ils découvrent les dégâts qu'ils
découvrent qu'ils sont vraiment
importants et vous êtes celle aussi qui
va devoir plus que moi et plus que les
générations précédentes accueillir et
gérer ce nouveau monde dans lequel nous
allons vivre ce monde très différent
dans lequel nous allons vivre et je vous
propose si vous le voulez bien ensemble
que nous réfléchissions à faire une
pause là parce que le développement
durable la transition énergétique la
transition écologique tout ça ça ne
marche pas on voit bien que les
résultats ne sont pas là je vous propose
de faire une pause de regarder un petit
peu ce que nous faisons deux côtés et je
vous propose pourquoi pas de réfléchir à
un moratoire scientifique et politique
sur l'écologie un moratoire scientifique
parce qu'évidemment on va on va faire
appel à la science celle que vous
étudiez ainsi et on va faire appel aux
politiques parce qu'il faudra maintenir
l'action il va continue il va falloir
continuer à agir et à maintenir une
adaptation possible à protéger notre
prochain et à protéger autant que
possible notre environnement
ce moratoire cette grande réflexion
pourront mener à partir de maintenant
c'est autour de trois questions que je
veux
le proposer ce moratoire première
question fondamentale à laquelle nous
aurions dû déjà répondre depuis
longtemps est ce que l'humanité est
capable de protéger son environnement
moi j'en sais rien et je ne peux pas le
présupposé d'autant plus que je constate
exactement l inverse nous constatons
exactement l inverse
nous devons commencer par nous poser
cette question est plutôt la pause et
maintenant qu'il est peut-être trop tard
pour certaines choses mais recommençons
ce travail deuxième question
fondamentale nous avons un problème
énergétique est il possible de
substituer une énergie par une autre
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas et l'histoire
montre exactement le contraire lorsque
le nucléaire est arrivé lorsque les
énergies renouvelables sont arrivées
elles se sont strictement additionné aux
autres modes de production d'énergie
sans aucune soustraction et dans
l'ensemble nous avons juste pour semer
beaucoup plus d'énergie
autre question troisième question elle
aussi fondamentale est vraiment subtil
et pénible même je dirais nous
investissons les nouveaux modes de
production d'énergie dit dit de
substitution le nucléaire les énergies
renouvelables photovoltaïque l'éolien en
espérant que ça se substitue un jour
d'autres modes de production plus
polluants on ne constate pas mais
aujourd'hui on constate même qu'il est
possible que ces nouveaux modes de
production aide à exploiter plus encore
les anciens je vais vous donner quatre
exemples il y en a beaucoup plus mais
vous vous en donner 4 aujourd'hui
certains certaines plate plate formes
pétrolières maritimes sont alimentés
littéralement par de l'énergie
renouvelable afin justement de pouvoir
plus encore alimenter nos sociétés avec
le pétrole qui est extrait du sol plutôt
que de se servir du pétrole pour
alimenter les plateformes pour aller
chercher de pétrole ce qui est absurde
donc on utilise les énergies
renouvelables pour finalement optimiser
notre extrême extraction de pétrole
aujourd'hui on fabrique des tours à
concentration solaire
vous voyez ce que c'est des grands
parterre de miroirs qui réfléchissent la
lumière du soleil dans une tour qui
chauffe de l'eau et c'est tout chauffé
est injecté dans le sol dans les nappes
de pétrole pour fluidifier ce fameux
pétrole très difficile à sortir du sol
on utilise de l'énergie solaire pour
finalement vous aurez compris et m
plus le gaz à effet de serre au final la
chine aujourd'hui reprend des essais qui
avait été menée aux états unis et au
xxème siècle sur une technique nucléaire
qui permet de fracturer le sol pour
faciliter l'extraction du gaz de schiste
lui aussi très difficile à sortir du sol
vous voyez que peut-être que ce que je
vous raconte est choquant par rapport à
ce qu'on entend habituellement dans les
discours écologique mais nous avons une
ambition de transition énergétique et ya
en face nous n'avons que des résultats
qui montrent que les émissions de co2
augmente chaque année et ces hypothèses
en l'occurrence la dernière que
j'appelle l'hypothèse du renforcement
synergique des énergies qu'elle soit
vraie ou fausse je n'en sais rien mais
nous devons la pause et en tant que
scientifique une pure une première piste
de réflexion plus accessible au
quotidien pour savoir si vraiment nous
sommes capables de protéger
l'environnement
posons nous la question quels cas
quelques actions que nous fassions une
action du quotidien ou une action avec
une vertu espérer de protection de
l'environnement
demandons nous si en fait cette
action-là quelle qu'elle soit elle
participe à faire vivre à permettre
l'existence du toucan du koala dans son
milieu naturel ou de n'importe quel être
vivant dans son milieu naturel
je n'en suis pas sûr je ne sais pas si
les actions que nous faisons raison
qu'elles qu'elles sont quelle qu'elle
soit ed la vie à se déployer sur la
planète terre c'est ce type de question
que nous devons nous poser pour savoir
où nous allons ensemble
vous êtes vraiment cette génération là
qui va devoir s'approprier ces nouveaux
défis puisque c'est le sujet de ce soir
moi je suis convaincu que ces défis là
sont les plus grands que l'humanité aura
peut-être jamais à se poser de toute son
existence
la question de savoir si l'humanité a
jamais protéger son environnement elle
est fondamentale peut-être qu'elle nous
définit en propre peut-être qu'elle est
rangé quelque part en nous coincé dans
notre inconscient avec nous avons du mal
à la faire ressortir pour la traiter et
du coup été vraiment notre prochain
vraiment ce défi là il est majeur
centrale pour moi et c'est un des fils
méritants
lorsque nous aurons répondu à cette
question quelle que soit la réponse
nous pourrons avancer éclairé vers
l'avenir ce défi là c'est pour moi bien
plus important que de retourner sur la
lune ou d'aller sur mars
très sincèrement c'est l'avenir de notre
humanité et de toute la vie sur la
planète qui se joue alors je sais bien
que j'ai eu un discours un peu plus
sombre que les autres ce soir mais je
suis convaincu d'une chose c'est que se
confrontaient frontalement à notre
nature aux contraintes physiques qui
nous montrent bien que nous ne sommes
pas tout puissant nous n'avons pas la
main sur la thermodynamique ou sur
l'entreprise c'est pas des choses que
nous avons inventé nous c'est des choses
qui étaient là avant nous nous ne sommes
pas dieu
il ya des paramètres de l'existence que
nous ne maîtrisons pas et je suis
convaincu qu'en tentant de répondre à la
question de savoir si l'humanité est
capable de protéger son environnement et
je reprendrai l'intitulé des conférences
de ce soir certes une part de l'avenir
est sombre mais je suis convaincu que
ces réflexions là ces nouveaux défis
sont la condition nécessaire pour
retrouver la lumière
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]